un tout autre sujet maintenant on
revient en séance avec le projet de loi
sur la santé
les sénateurs ont voté hier soir un
article important les sages femmes
pourront désormais pratiquer des ivg
médicamenteuses la commission des
affaires sociales du sénat avait
supprimé cet article mais les sénateurs
par un vote à main levée l'on rétablit
la ministre de la santé marisol touraine
a défendu cette mesure comme une réponse
de proximité pour les femmes qui
souhaitent avorter la sénatrice les
républicains fabienne keller a de son
côté expliqué que chaque année 6000
femmes sont contraintes de se rendre à
l'étranger car elles ne parviennent pas
à trouver de solution à proximité dans
les délais légaux voilà tout de suite
donc on va suivre ce débat dans
l'hémicycle
nous reprenons la suite de la discussion
du projet de loi adopté par l'assemblée
nationale après engagement de la
procédure accélérée de modernisation de
notre système de santé dans la
discussion des articles nous sommes
parvenus à l'article 31 et à l'article
31 nous avons l'abonnement 776 madame
cohen vous avez la parole
oui monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues cet
amendement ainsi que ceux qui suivent
iso rétablissement de l'article tel
qu'adopté par l'assemblée nationale
permettant notamment aux sages femmes de
pratiquer les ivg médicamenteuses avec
le recours aux médecins en cas de
complications si le droit à l'avortement
était un acquis majeur est un droit
fondamental des femmes
fruit d'un long combat ce droit reste
fragile et en pratique l'accès universel
parfois problématique comme le souligne
un rapport récent du haut conseil à
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
liv et j est un événement assez courant
de la vie sexuelle et reproductive des
femmes puisque on estime que près d'une
femme sur trois aura recours à l'image
et au cours de sa vie les interruptions
volontaires de grossesse dit
médicamenteuse représente aujourd'hui
plus de la moitié des avortements
pratiqués en france
ce chiffre est en hausse depuis 2009
alors que depuis les années 2000 on
assistait à la fermeture de plus de 130
établissements de santé pratiquant les
ivg la pratique de l'ibg s'est concentré
sur certains établissements entraînant
des effets des tremblements et de files
d'attentes avec des délais pour les
prises de rendez vous le manque de
moyens de personnel contribue à rendre
le parcours de soins difficile et peu
accessible
pour les femmes on a dit d'ailleurs que
de nombreux médecins militants entre
guillemets partent à la retraite et
qu'ils sont pas obligatoirement
remplacés par des médecins ayant les
mêmes conceptions la possibilité pour
les sages femmes de réaliser les ivg
médicamenteuse est une avancée
permettant de faciliter l'accès à l'ivg
et j'ai tout en reconnaissant le rôle
des sages femmes dans le système de
santé afin de garantir les conditions de
sécurité de la pratique de
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
médicamenteuse nous demandons à
maintenir le recours au médecin en cas
de complications et j'en profite
également pour vous alerter à nouveau
sur le manque cruel de gynécologues
médical même si madame la ministre vous
avez fait en sorte qu'il y en ait plus
pour nous étendre les compétences des
sage-femmes doit bien se faire au nom de
la santé des femmes et non pas au
détriment des gynécologues comme pour
pallier une pénurie
je vous remercie donc de bien vouloir
prendre en compte ces éléments et y
compris pouvoir nous apporter des
éléments supplémentaires
merci madame cohen cas l'avis de la
commission merci monsieur le président à
lima à l'image de la série d'amendements
que nous apprêtons à examiner
l'amendement 776 vise essentiellement à
rétablir les dispositions supprimées par
notre commission qui entendent donner
compétence de sages-femmes pour réaliser
donc des ivg médicamenteuses il nous
paraît absolument indispensable que la
réalisation d'une ivg continue de se
faire tout au long des étapes de cette
intervention par un médecin sous sa
responsabilité et son suivi j'ajoute que
l'élargissement de compétence qui est
proposé ne paraît pas et loin de là
faire consensus chez les sages femmes
psion nat nous a tout reçu des oeufs en
a qui étaient favorables et d'autre il
était éthique étaient défavorables et
pour beaucoup d'entre aide pour cette
double raison la commission a fait le
choix de supprimer les dispositions
concernées nous donnons donc à la
commission donne donc un avis
défavorable à l'ensemble des amendements
qui entendent revenir sur cette
suppression monsieur le président
je termine en précisant que cet
amendement 67 176 rétabli par ailleurs
des dispositions qui n'ont pas lieu de
l'être car elles n'ont pas été
supprimées par notre commission il
s'agit en particulier de la possibilité
pour les sages femmes de pratiquer des
vaccinations des personnes qui vivent
dans l'entourage du nouveau né merci
madame le ministre
oui madame la sénatrice l'objectif que
vous affirmez est partagée par le
gouvernement puisque la volonté que je
porte c'est que les sages femmes
puissent pratiquer des interruptions
volontaires de grossesse médicamenteuse
c'est une réponse de proximité
c'est une réponse parmi d'autres
possibles pour des femmes qui souhaitent
avorter est l'un des enjeux aujourd'hui
c'est de permettre la diversification
des lieux où l'on peut pratiquer en
toute sécurité évidemment des
interruptions volontaires de grossesse
donc sur cette partie là de votre
amendement je suis est aujourd'hui plus
encore que n'importe quel autre jour
puisque c'est la journée de tous nous
comment dire nous célébrons le droit à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
mais donc je partage votre approche au
delà de la remarque a fait le président
rapporteur sur des difficultés de
rédaction vous ajoutez dans votre texte
une obligation de formation qui ne
paraît pas nécessaire dans sa
spécificité et c'est la raison pour
laquelle je vous demanderais de bien
vouloir retirer votre amendement au
bénéfice de l'amendement présenté par
madame d'édition ou portés par madame
joly sont 477 rectifié qui reprend
une rédaction qui a fait l'objet d'un
travail
j'ajoute à destination de ceux le
président-rapporteur que nous ne voyons
pas les mêmes sages femmes alors parce
que elles ont exprimé massivement leur
soutien il y a eu des communiqués
publics de soutien à cette démarche qui
est une un soutien attendu est
d'ailleurs j'observe que lorsque les
sages femmes ont revendiqué pour une
plus grande commande et reconnaissance
de leurs droits
l'année dernière on entendait sur tous
les bancs d appel vibrant à faire en
sorte qu'elle soit pleinement reconnue
c'est là une des traductions concrètes
de cette avancée en leur direction dans
l'intérêt des femmes bien entendu donc
demande de retrait ou avis défavorable
merci madame la ministre madame cohen
vous êtes sollicité pour un retrait au
profit de l'amendement suivant côté je
vais retirer mon amendement au profit du
suivant parce que je pense que c'est
très important compte tenu de ce que
j'ai évoquées qui nous tient à coeur
on a intervient souvent au niveau de mon
groupe et moi part personnellement au
niveau des fermetures de centres
d'interruption volontaire de grossesse
en prenant en compte le fait que
nombreuses sont les femmes hélas qui
sont obligés de recourir à des
avortements en changeant en devant
quitter la france voilà pour toutes ces
raisons je vais donc accédé à la demande
de madame la ministre en précisant quand
même et je le redis que il ne faudrait
pas que cette cette mesure en fait
perdre de vue le fait qu' il y ait quand
même besoin d'avoir un recours
une référence aux médecins puisque on le
fait quand il y à des grossesses
pathologiques et cetera
je pense qu'il ne faut pas banaliser
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse y
compris qu'elles soient médicamenteuse
ou instrumentales c'est pourquoi
j'insiste sur ces notions là et de même
justice sur le fait que les
les gynécologues nous ont vraiment
alertés sur le fait qu'il y a besoin
aussi de prendre en compte leurs
spécificités et de ne pas de ne pas
penser que en élargissant les
responsabilités des sages-femmes
finalement eh bien on règlerait les
problèmes de la gynécologie
médicamenteuse donc comme j'ai le
sentiment d'avoir été écoutés et un peu
entendu donc je vais retirer mon
amendement
merci madame cohen donc le 776 est
retirée nous passons à huit amendements
discussion commune le 477 rectifier
c'est madame rio cru qu'il défend donc
cet amendement concerne l'élargissement
du champ des compétences des sage-femmes
aux ivg médicamenteuse à l'examen post
natale et aux vaccinations
cet article a trait à l'élargissement du
champ de compétences des sage-femmes son
objectif est triple autorisé la pratique
d'une ivg médicamenteuses permettre
d'effectuer les examens post natale et
la possibilité de vacciner le nouveau né
est la maman
or l'ensemble des dispositions
autorisant les sages femmes à pratiquer
les ivg médicamenteuse a disparu du
texte suite à leur suppression par la
commission des affaires sociales du
sénat
celle ci a en effet considéré
l'indispensable nécessité de supervision
de ces ivg par un médecin pourtant la
présence d'un médecin est elle vraiment
nécessaire dès lors que l'on n'est pas
dans le cadre d'une ivg instrumentale
mais dans la dispensation d'un
médicament
nous ne le pensons pas les sages-femmes
nous sommes plus que qualifier pour cet
acte et ce d'autant plus qu'elles
bénéficient déjà de la formation requise
pour pratiquer les interruptions de
grossesse par voie médicamenteuse
par ailleurs c'est élargissement de
compétences correspond à un besoin clair
l'axé ali vg est de plus en plus ardu
des centres ferment et les médecins qui
le pratique se font plus rares comme l'a
souligné ma collègue madame cohen nous
ne pouvons que partager ce constat il
est largement demandé est soutenue par
les sages femmes que nous avons
rencontrées elles sont plus que
légitimes à pouvoir le pratiquer elles
sont en effet les mieux placés pour
soutenir les femmes dans cette épreuve
où l'accompagnement est primordial est
le 888 rectifié suivant n'est pas
soutenue
nous passerons 8 rectifié qui le défend
je vois monsieur opère non vous en êtes
signataire le 8 rectifier
je suis bon prince
oui oui je suis président monsieur le
président de la commission madame la
ministre
c'est tellement est défendue il a pour
but de rétablir la le numéro 1 de
l'article 31 pour établir les
dispositions concernant l'intervention
des sages femmes dans le cadre des ivg
médicamenteuses prévue par le projet de
loi initial
certaines de ces modifications proposées
à l'article l de 22 12 3 du code de la
santé publique complète des
modifications suggérées par des
précédents amendements aux articles 22
15 5 et 22 12 6 de ce code pour limiter
les délais d'attentes des ivg le 840 de
rectifier madame keller l'identique
oui merci beaucoup comme vous le disiez
à l'instant madame la ministre voilà 40
ans que la loi était la loi veil les
promulguer pour ceux qui ont mon âge ou
plus on se souvient du procès de bobigny
heureusement la société a beaucoup
évolué sur ce sujet mme l ivg est resté
tout à fait considérable accompagner les
femmes de manière aussi humaine que
possible les informer les sensibiliser
dans ce moment qui est toujours un
moment dramatique pour elle un moment de
choix
c'est donc je crois notre priorité très
partagés
le l'amendement que je propose qui est
identique au précédent vise après
autoriser les sages-femmes elle aussi à
pratiquer cette technique un peu moins
terrible que ce qui est plus
chirurgicale qui l ivg médicamenteuses
les sages femmes ont l'habitude des
femmes
en situation de désespoir de fragilité
psychologique et de difficultés
physiques elles seront comme elles le
font toujours
réorienter vers un médecin celles qui
ont besoin d'un complément de
consultation plus technique mais l'objet
de ces de l'ensemble de ces amendements
c'est tout simplement d'ouvrir un peu à
des professionnels formés la possibilité
de donner accès à l'ivg et médicamenteux
sachant chers collègues je crois que
notre objectif à tous c'est de réduire
c'est plus de 200000 ivg annuels' une
femme sur trois qui le vit encore un
moment de vie très difficiles l'ouvrir
aux sages-femmes ne changera pas la
réalité de ces deux cent mille femmes et
pourra peut-être voilà adoucir un tout
petit peu ce moment difficile
et au passage pour des territoires où
les suivi gynécologique sont assurés par
des sages-femmes et plus ponctuellement
par des médecins
cela garantit un accès et une rapidité
de réponse qui ne pourraient pas être
assurée je vous remercie
merci madame tenait alors le stratifié
bis monsieur opère il est des pendus
damman défendu par madame keller le 9
rectifié monsieur opère ainsi que le
descriptif y est d'ailleurs
idem idem donc ils en arrivent en 843
rectifié madame keller d'appeler à
nouveau à vous on est sur le même sujet
c'est un point plus rédactionnelle ça
vise à rétablir la mention de vg
médicamenteuse parmi les compétences des
sage-femmes j'ai pas évoqué mais
d'autres collègues l'ont fait celles qui
malheureusement dépasse souvent la les
12 semaines et sont amenés à aller à
l'étranger donc on est on est dans cette
logique d'ouverture sens
oublier que de nombres sage femme assure
déjà des consultations psychosocial dans
des centres de planification dans des
centres de pmi et donc voilà j'ai envie
de dire c'est la réalité de leur mission
que l'accompagnement des femmes aussi
dans ce moment douloureux qu'on ne
souhaite à personne de choix d'être
obligé d'interrompre sa grossesse vous
remercier
merci alors monsieur le rapporteur
quelle est la vie de la commune je me
suis exprimé tout à l'heure mais ce
président pour vous dire que la
commission avait donné un avis
défavorable sur l'ensemble de ces
amendements donc elle n'a pas changé
d'avis depuis
je voudrais juste ajouter quand même à
mes collègues que si on peut comprendre
ce qui vient d'être dit ce qui vient
d'être réclamés je vous rappelle quand
même que la place mais le dernier
actionnaire en prestige emea semaine
précédente
le sénat a maintenu la suppression du
délai de réflexion plus madame la
ministre
oui donc de façon de faire dans le
prolongement de ce que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure
évidemment je donne un avis favorable à
l'amendement présenté par madame riz au
creux il ya quelques instants qui vise à
rétablir dans le texte le rôle des sages
femmes pour les vg médicamenteuse de
manière cohérente c'est à dire en
identifiant à la fois leurs rôles
responsabilités la cotation des actes ce
qui est nécessaire
les amendements 8 rectifié 342 rectifié
6 rectifié bis propose un rétablissement
mais partielle qui n'est pas aussi
complet que celui pour porter par madame
marie au creux et donc je demande le
retrait au bénéfice de celui porté par
madame rio creux ou avis défavorable à
l'amendement numéro 843 présenté par
madame keller propose de rétablir
d'autres dispositions cohérente avec la
démarche proposée de reconnaître la
place des sages-femmes et c'est donc un
avis favorable à cet amendement 843
rectifier très bien alors nous allons
passer au vote
en commençant par le 477 rectifié
identique au 1 888 rectifier
avec un avis défavorable de la
commission et l'avis favorable du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre
la demande les deux amendements sont
adoptés et donc le 8 rectifié tombe le
840 de rectifier tombe
par définition le ainsi que le 6 le 9 et
le 10 pas le dise alors donc je mets aux
voix le dise rectifié donc avec un avis
défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement
si j'ai bien compris donc et pour qui et
contre il n'est pas adoptée et le 843
rectifié n'est pas tombé donc je le mets
aux voix avec un avis défavorable de la
commission est favorable du gouvernement
c'est bien cela donc époux qui est
content qui s'abstient le 843 rectifier
et adopté voilà vous ai donc pu suivre
la suite de l'examen du projet de loi de
modernisation du système de santé les
sénateurs ont voté hier un article
important qui autorise les sages femmes
a désormais pratiquer des ivg
médicamenteuses
vous pouvez revoir bien sûr ce programme
sur notre site internet publicsenat.fr